مع رؤية نعم للقضاء على كاديما قلت لحرق
يا هذا، استمع إلى الإرهابيين هناك، لا أعتقد أنه يوجد أي منهم
مخطئ في الأشياء أقف وراء أشياءي
في كل مرة نرى أيضًا ما يحدث هناك من ناحية
في الحرب حرق المباني خير من هدمها
إذا كانت الأشياء مؤلمة، فمن المستحيل أن نكون جميلين
في المنزل وقل اه هناك أبرياء هناك نعم من
ليس لدي نقطة لا تزال هناك
ليس لدي شك حتى أن الرئيس قال بالحرق
تجرؤ على الحرق، ماذا تعني، ادخل واقرأ
أعني أنه لا يوجد فكر هنا، ولا حتى واحد
التقدير أنت تفهم أن جنود الجيش لا يفعلون ذلك
سيفكرون للحظة واحدة ويتألمون بسببنا
يجب أن تكونوا حرفيين، نعم، لقد بدأ بشكل جيد
القضاء على الإرهابيين كان ولكن في النهاية جاء
احرق كل هذا فأنت تعلم أن هناك مقولة تقول
ونحن جميعا نعرف التحذير من الحكمة والصمت في هذا الشأن
حتى بيل الأصم والذكي سيأخذ في الاعتبار ذلك، أما نحن فلا
ليس نحن فقط من يحتاج إلى هذه الأشياء
من الضروري أن نفهم أن آلهة مير هي بيان
سيظهر باتوري في المناقشة غدًا مما يعني أن الأمر سيكون سلسًا
من الحجج
لينة جنوب أفريقيا التي نديرها أولاً
هنا مغالطة منطقية أساسية، نقول ذلك إذا
سنواصل حرب السنوار بهذه الحدة
سيوافق على أن يكون رهينة ما دام السيف تحت إمرته
أما إذا وافق على إعادة المختطفين فسيكون ذلك
حتى أنه نزع السيف عن أمر عوديد الذي طلبته مطلقاً
عندما نتحدث عن الحرب ماذا يعني ذلك؟
يقولون حتى النهاية سوف ينتصر لوش خان على رفح حتى النهاية
النصر حتى تدمير همس ميتوت همس كيشول
حماس لا تقول الحقيقة لأن العصر قد انتهى
انتهت الانتصارات وصور النصر والنصر
وكان آخرها في أكتوبر
1973 ميدانياً داخل قطاع غزة نموذجاً تجريبياً
أنا شخصياً أسمع ذلك شخصياً عبر الإنترنت
السياق في الفضاء الذي نحن فيه هو هذا
الوضع الجيش يروي قصصا عظيمة
في وسائل الإعلام والمتحدث باسم الجيش يأتي كل يوم ويخبر الناس
إسرائيل، ما يحدث داخل القطاع، الوضع الفعلي قليلا
شونا سمعت يوم واحد قاعدين في واحد
مواقع حماس الاستيطانية التي استولينا عليها بعد غارة معقدة
وكان هناك جرحى أيضا، ونحن نجلس في واحد
مكاتب هابس موجودة في إحدى المحطات داخل نحن
نحن نعلم أن هناك تهديدات ضدنا، ونحن خائفون
اخرجوا لأننا نعلم أن هناك تهديدات
في ذلك الوقت، كان هناك أقل عدد ممكن من المخارج، ولا يوجد مخارج
دعهم يرون شبكة فوقنا حتى لا يضربونا بقناص
ونحن نستمع إلى الأخبار بهذا الراديو الصغير
نسمع قائد الكعكة لدينا في الأخبار
كنت في الكعكة 162 يقول قائد الكعكة لدينا
أننا قريبون جدًا من التحكم التشغيلي
في الميدان أخشى أن أترك IIT وقائد الكعكة الخاص بي
يقول إنني ديوان مضطرب اليوم في الكنيست في وضع
مقاولو الترميم في إسرائيل الذين يعانون من النقص ح
هناك عمال أجانب أو فلسطينيين كرئيس
هدد مقاولو التجديد آرني سيب بمناقشة المقاول
قتلت نفسك بسبب الحكومة
من الجيد هنا أن تقرر ألا تقرر الشيء الأفضل
يمكن أن تكون موجودة في العالم ولكن الناس يداهمونك
أرجل الناس هنا يكتسحون الناس هنا لا قدر الله
ستخسر أيضاً، نحتاج إلى حلول لأنه لا يوجد أي حلول
لقد حلوا مشاكل الأشخاص المخدوعين في دولة إسرائيل
والده لديه منزل والدولة هي الحكومة
نحن بحاجة لصيد السمك لشعبها
سنرى الأشياء التي يخبرنا بها الليلة عن الأيام
مصيرية للاقتصاد وتنتظر الأسواق لمعرفة ما إذا كان
وستتبع الحكومة المسار الذي أوصى به المحافظ والقواعد
المهنية في الخزينة أو عن طريق تجاهل إشارات المرور
التحذير الاقتصادي قلناه عند إشارة المرور
التحذير هنا هو أنه لا يمكن لأحد أن يقول لا
نحن نعرف الآن ملاحظة أيونية صغيرة أخرى عنها
الجرأة الكبيرة للحكومة سوف تجعلك تقطع 100 دولار
مليون شيكل
من موازنة سلة الأدوية ولكن مستمرين في التوزيع
أموال التحالف بالمليارات من الأموال
تخفيضات الرشوة السياسية النظيفة الآن 78
مليون شيكل من موازنة وزارة الرفاه لكن لا
- إغلاق المكاتب غير الضرورية للوزراء الذين لا يعملون
لا شيء فقط لوضع الوظائف السياسية على كل شيء
ويدفع الشعب الثمن الاقتصادي الباهظ
هذه الحكومة ولا يراها إلا رئيس الوزراء والوزراء
لقد ضحكنا من خلال وضع شريط ميزانية للجبناء حتى
لذا، نعم، ما الذي سأطلبه، لكن دعنا نقول لا
كانت ستكون هناك حرب ولم تكن هناك هذه الكارثة
وكانوا سيشعرون بالميزانية، كان الأمر مختلفًا كثيرًا، لا
وكأن العالم كعادته يعامل فقراء هذه الفئة
ليس لدي كلمة أخرى، لم يحدث شيء
يخاف من لمس الأماكن المؤلمة
من الناحية السياسية، فإنهم يفضلون ترك السيدة ستراك معها
هذه الأموال الفاسدة وأخرجها من السلة
المال هو العقل لا يدرك هذه الأشياء
نحن لا نتنافس، لن أمزق الشوا في قرني
يجب عليهم وعلى ميتز أن يأتوا إلى الجمهور ويقولوا إن الوضع صعب
وعليك اتخاذ خطوات صعبة اليوم فقط تلقيت
متطلبات التخفيضات وموازنة وزارة التربية والتعليم
وهذا يعني ضررا جسيما للعنصر التربوي برمته
للمكتب وهذا دون الحديث حتى عن الطلب
ليس لدينا إضافة للمهجرين في الشمال والجنوب
يمكننا أن نعمل مثل هذا
معارض